[Music]
this video was filmed at a hospital in
Wuhan the center of the corona virus
epidemic I'm being wound in yesterday
and I was talking to Kentucky Neola from
this angle kina was awake after that you
see a bar apart and this is footage of a
hospital under construction code for
ambien behind the camera are two
vloggers who have become sensations in
China Fang bian is a resident of Wuhan
and Changsha Shay a human rights lawyer
the two vloggers who are known in China
as citizen journalists published
unfiltered video reports as the crisis
unfolded in late January and early
February scenes that haven't appeared in
China's tightly controlled state media
but they stopped posting videos in early
february fellow activists and relatives
said they have disappeared
come on oh my god oh shoot Chen's mother
posted a video saying she wasn't able to
contact her son according to a friend
the police told Chan's father that his
son was held in quarantine
activists say neighbors of Phong saw
uniformed and plainclothes police
officers take him away the activists
haven't seen him since even if their
images were only available online for
days or even hours China experts say it
is unusual for Beijing authorities to
let this form of open criticism up here
before censoring content or clamping
down on its creators many citizens have
spoken up from doctors and nurses to
people stuck at home and patients
challenging the official narrative of
hospitals being speedily built from
scratch and armies of volunteers orderly
working to contain the epidemic so how
are these videos critical of authorities
getting out into the public
Beijing officials have said there is a
genuine desire to promote accurate
information about the epidemic and block
false reports that could increase panic
nonetheless the anger in China came to a
tipping point late January after people
accused local authorities of trying to
cover up what was happening people was
not informed in the three to four weeks
what we have witnessed is the revolt of
the Chinese people
Valpo publishes books from Hong Kong on
topics that are censored by Beijing he
says people grew frustrated when they
saw the healthcare system was
overwhelmed by the coronavirus
especially after the SARS epidemic that
took nearly 800 lives in 2002 and 2003
people generally expect the government
have learned the lessons of a thar's
epidemic so they should have fed up
various mechanism to prevent that from
ever happening who says the speed at
which the criticism piled up online
might be too hard for China's censorship
apparatus to manage and that is one
reason Chinese citizens have managed to
share content online tens of millions
have been stuck at home leading to a
surge in the number of people reading
and using social media another
explanation according to researchers
might be that in this situation Beijing
needs information to keep flowing
because this is a health crisis people
also need to talk about you know
supplies and access and they need to be
able to discuss this otherwise they're
kind of stuck at home and quarantine
zone it becomes really insufferable so
they can complete these censor all
discussions
Maria rep Nick OVA analyzes how Beijing
censors its citizens and says she
believes the government intentionally
opened the doors to criticism useful
some ways to learn about what's
happening while it's only the early
stages the crisis you know the state
officials at the local central that will
still don't quite know what are they one
of the bigger issues worth one of the
big frustration so it's kind of a way to
get public opinion on this you know try
to understand the grievances and then
respond to that Rep Nick OVA has
interviewed over 100 Chinese journalists
and officials about big crises like
mining disasters or the 2008 Sichuan
earthquake she noticed there's a limited
window of opportunity for journalists to
cover these events and citizens to
complain
Rep Nick OVA says during the Sichuan
earthquake the government started to
tape mouth shut when journalists
reported that poorly built schools had
contributed to the deaths of hundreds of
children in Wuhan Fang bian was able to
publish 33 videos in 16 days on YouTube
one video he posted online shows that he
had run-ins with people who identified
themselves as local health officials who
wanted to check Vaughn's health because
he had visited a hospital one said the
men confiscated his computer and phone
then drove him to the outskirts of the
city to continue questioning him
activists say he disappeared a week
later a Chinese diplomat was asked about
Fong during a TV interview I believe the
relevant authorities and departments in
China the legal departments are dealing
with the case in accordance with law ha
which camera being a horror film with a
fine listener leader authorities have
made no public statement about Chen's
disappearance or thongs were abouts the
disappearance of both men in early
February happened around the time when
the death toll in China came closer to
surpassing the one from SARS this is
also approximately when Beijing began
ramping up efforts to create a new
narrative that things were under control
even though Chinese officials have
continually offered assurances that the
epidemic is being successfully managed
state-controlled media have now put the
blame on local authorities for a slow
response to contain the outbreak in
Wuhan while praising central authorities
for quickly pouring resources into the
center of the crisis many ways crises
are also opportunities for political
systems to come out as the winners or
Victor's or you know kind of as being in
charge of this state of affairs about a
month after the disappearance of Chun
and
health officials said the number of new
infections had fallen dramatically in
China authorities reported new
infections in double digits down from
hundreds of cases a day the outcry on
Chinese social media even if short-lived
shows that many people in the country
don't buy the government's message that
the crisis is under control